flush em is a set of powerful data
manipulation querying tools here's a
short example that shows how flash M can
work with Excel spreadsheets first we'll
open a typical spreadsheet
in this case we have financial data
about countries in Europe notice the
information in the spreadsheet is in a
semi structured form that isn't easy to
work with each country has several value
year pairs where the values are dollars
suppose you wanted to find the sum of
the values for the years 1950 first we
use flash relate to put our data into a
structured format we specify the number
of desired columns 3 next we provide an
example like this
and now we provide a second example
at this point we click the learn button
and then the run button now we have our
data in a usable form we can use flash
fill dollar signs to our money column
like this click the Run button
and then click the confirm button there
we go and next we can use analyze to
query our data using natural language
like this
and there's our answer this short
example demonstrates only a few of
flashy ohms powerful capabilities for
more information contact Summa Kewanee
or Ben Zorn in the Microsoft research
and software engineering group